I'll make this video quick not just
because that's what I usually aim to
achieve with my videos but because based
on my previous content of this nature
it'll likely be nerfed pretty soon after
this won't show you how to get 100
classifieds an hour or anything but it
still feels like the quickest and most
reliable way at this stage especially if
you're running solo using this method
will give you up to three classified
pieces in 30 minutes possibly more if
you're better accelerating resistance to
me which to be fair wouldn't be that
hard first you need to equip your best
solo built here I'm using my six piece
d3 if NC sit I'll leave a link to the
build in the description after that head
over and start up one of the resistance
missions make your way through the early
waves and head towards the first
resistance reward chest
it'll be behind a door that costs 7,500
s HD tech to unlock farm the NPC's to
gain as many credits as possible
remember to delay killing the bosses in
wave 5 and 10 as long as you can so that
more NPCs are spawned in allowing you to
gain more credits the resistance reward
chest has a very high chance of dropping
classified pieces most of the time would
click 2 to 3 classifieds per run each
run taking about 30 minutes you'll also
have an additional chance that another
classified through the tier 2 resistance
cache that you gain from completing the
wave 10 bosses the first reward will
cost you 1500 is HD tech with each
consecutive reward costing you 1500 more
than the last by the time you reach wave
15 with the 3 hunter bosses you should
have unlocked 3 rewards from the chest
if you can go further good luck but
usually at this point I would restart
and repeat this could be running teams
too but the required tech to open the
reward chest steps up considerably so
depending on the team it probably isn't
worth while for example a team of 2
would have the first reward costing 3000
instead of 1,500 and a team of 3 or more
would cost 6000 running in a team of 2
isn't too bad as long as one of you is
pretty well geared you'll only be able
to open to reward chips before wave 15
but the advantages that you'll be able
to share what you receive in my opinion
this is the fastest way for a solo
player to gain classified pieces I've
had a fair amount of luck in the dark
zone but there's a huge amount of rng
involved there and on a lucky day you
still wouldn't be getting up to 3 pieces
in half an hour anyway if this has
helped you please let me know below
otherwise I'll catch you next time
Cheers
[Music]